it's like saying that you want to be a
boxer
but like after you get really good at
boxing you'll never have to take a punch
again
it's like no the sport people that's the
sport of the game we're playing
all right this is michael seibel with
dalton caldwell and today we're going to
talk about dealing with setbacks
needless to say in both of our startups
we experienced a wide variety of
setbacks and i think working with so
many startups over the last 10 years
what's probably become most obvious to
us is how
i don't think i've ever seen founders
who don't um get hit with a lot of
punches like dodging the punches
impossible like even i'll freeze another
way you might dodge some of the punches
but some of the punches are going to
land
so this is going to be a bit of a talk
about
what types of punches land and what you
might have to deal with if you're in
this game for a long time what do you
think dalton did did y'all have a couple
punches land over the years yeah i mean
that was that was my experience as a
founder was taking punches constantly
and i think what comes up in office
hours with me a lot man is
i think people want to talk to me about
one specific thing and asking for advice
about that thing
and i'm happy to do it but a lot of what
i want to encourage them to think about
is the meta thing
which is that the thing will keep
happening over and over again
and so
developing a set of skills of
identifying a situation of like oh this
is one of these where like something bad
happened
and approaching it is part of like the
sun rises the sun sets
bad things happen
you know like it's this is
this is as much a part of of being a
startup founder as literally anything
else versus thinking you you're never
gonna have them or that each each
setback is different
they're not they just come just like
every sunrise comes right so
let's jump into the first
area that produces setbacks investors in
fundraising the classic the classic
i went in fundraise with this
expectation i came out with a bloody
nose and a black eye
yeah i thought
i thought they liked me i thought they
were my friends i thought i was special
i thought
everyone else is raising
you know everyone else is this oh i i
got all the right intros
i know they're interested in my thing i
did the networking like it's it's some
version of
i
believed with good reason x was going to
happen
[Music]
x did not happen
wtf like
like how dare they or the universe like
you end up like going kind of nuts
on feeling wronged by a person or a or a
system or
uh whatever you want to call it like
someone did you wrong right
what i think the scary thing about
fundraising is that one fundraising
process can
produce so many of these experiences
so many of them and you know i remember
personally
the first full partnership meeting
like we were raising a round like from a
real investor and i had my first full
partnership meeting
and i remember thinking like this is it
like this is you know
this is destiny like this is gonna
happen like
you know it's taken me so many meetings
to get here
and i remember in front of everyone one
of the vcs in the meeting
eviscerated me for 45 minutes and
everyone else was quiet and the person
who like invited me to the meeting was
quiet and i just watched that person
very logically take apart my entire
startup almost in a way that i would
have had our roles been reversed it was
like it's like well they were they were
probably right right they were right no
no it wasn't they weren't wrong right
but like you know in some way they were
right in other ways i think we were
right i mean our company did well in the
end but precisely yeah yeah you you
could take apart any startup
logically at that stage like where
there's no defense and i just remember
leaving that meeting being like oh [ __ ]
like
i can't imagine how i felt an hour ago
compared to how i feel now okay
literally those seem like two different
years of my life we see this at yc where
like you know statistically most folks
don't get into yc
this is the game
and you see the way folks react to it
in very different ways when we deal with
the context of yc founders
the best people who don't get in
realize this isn't a one-shot game yeah
they apply again they make progress to
their company like
you know we we send a reject email to
every company and like the best people
will be like you know you're making good
points we're gonna we're gonna improve
on those things and we'll we'll
apply again
and i think that like they realize that
that's
that's a plus what like you like you
you've earned some respect in that
moment
like put another way there's an
opportunity to get an advantage even
when you feel like you just failed
whereas almost the worst founders feel
like oh now the game is off
if i like curse
it won't be counted because the you know
it's
the the time is over right like the you
know nothing's counted after the clock
runs to zero and it's like the game's
not off like what are you talking about
and we see this all the time with series
a's where man i talk about this so much
um
no one puts out a press release when
they fail to raise an a
yeah
so what's going on is most a's fail
but no one ever tells anyone but
everyone tells everybody when it
succeeds and so it creates this warped
reality that everyone thinks everyone is
raising a's and everyone has an easy
time everyone but me
is raising a series a everyone but me is
having an easy time what's wrong with me
and it's like no no no no no like i
think it's just the virtue by which this
information is shared
and so people have this warped view of
reality
that causes everyone to think that they
are personally
you know
everything bad has happened to them and
to no one else
well and this touches on the next
subject which is co-founders
because you know this is something that
i definitely experience you know my
co-founders are reading techcrunch
watching idiots raise tens of millions
of dollars every day and then looking at
me as the fundraiser being like
hey mike like what's going on
like there's a a couple of idiots with
no products just raised 10 million from
you know dotted off famous fund why why
is our series a taking this long
and
man co-founder fights suck you know
co-founder disputes
they are the
in some ways i think it rocks you to
your core more than
investor issues because like that's your
home like when your home feels broken oh
it feels bad
and yc we encourage people to do
startups with their friends and i think
that a lot of people think about that
and they say well
that seems so risky like if my startup
doesn't work won't my friendship break
and you know we always talk about the
other side of that which is like if you
don't have a strong relationship with
this person when things go bad it's
guaranteed to break you know
at least if you have a friendship
there's a fighting chance every
cofounder relationship is always tested
right and so you want to have enough
connective tissue
that like you can survive the inevitable
friction
and to think that there will never be
friction that's not again not realistic
and so you actually want to have enough
of a relationship so when the inevitable
friction happens
there's still a relationship and it's
not just like boom
so the other thing that comes up a lot
is this concept of the magical deal
and and i always love the magical deal
because like the magical deal can punch
you in the face when it doesn't happen
and the magical deal can punch you in
the face when it does happen because it
turns out it's not as magical as you
thought it's our first six-figure
advertising contract with microsoft
which we were like oh man this is it
like this is this breaks open our entry
into the monetization game
which required us to redesign our entire
site
go to la and produce a live television
show
lose way more than a hundred thousand
dollars of money
the show wasn't very good and
complete waste of time and effort like
literally three months of our lives like
down the drain
and if we think about the burn we had
during that period of time like let
alone we didn't make money on the
advertising like the burn
in the wasted opportunity
um
and to me it's like wow but at the
moment we were like these are the deals
that will save the company like this is
the most important thing happening
you see that a lot right the the founder
is like this is the magical here's the
the potion this is what's gonna yeah i
think it's that you reduce
your entire startup to you just need one
thing to happen and then you're on easy
street i always picture you know at the
end of the movie when they roll credits
you know like something happens
and then like the music plays
and they you know roll credits like we
won like i think people think that's how
life actually is
and they're like yeah well once i get
this deal you know roll credits
and what's funny working with a lot of
startups and when i was a founder is
sometimes you'd get the deal
and the credits don't roll you're like
oh now what
you're
i thought the movie was over
and then you're like [ __ ]
i guess i guess we actually have to like
run a startup still
okay we got to know i see michael like
where are we rich like
are we we won right we're successful
we have to we have to break this news to
people all the time to get into ycu that
like
it's still hard i love that too because
i think
founders
have this moment have this thought in
their head that that moment is going to
be in the first two and a half years
like the play the credits off
it's it's all inevitable from here we'll
be in the first two and a half years
and we talk to so many alums who are
like eight to ten years to their
ridiculously successful companies no
music like no no credits no
public companies no credits like like no
they're still still doing it and it's
still the same property like they have
setbacks i think
like it's no fun like these people have
a hard time like they have constant
setbacks
constant setbacks i mean that's the game
it's it's like saying like i don't know
it's like saying that you want to be a
boxer
but like after you get really good at
boxing you'll never have to take a punch
again
it's like no the sport people that's the
sport that's the game we're playing
if you want to reach that like retire
stop
if you don't want to take punches stop
playing this game
um you had some thoughts on when a
launch goes bad
yeah i mean i think a lot of folks
think that launches will be like the
movie again i think i think we're we
can't help but be influenced by
television and movie and books where you
know
actual an actual realistic movie that
showed a startup would just be like
people sitting at their keyboard typing
all day not talking probably would be
like lots of that punctuated by pretty
boring conversations but that's not
that's not good in a movie and so so
anyway i think this translates to how
people think a launch will go where they
think they're gonna launch
and everyone's gonna care and like
things will happen to them and like you
know like they have a movie in their
head of all these like amazing things
happening and all these users signing up
and the reason it's really good to
launch fast is to get that [ __ ] out of
your head as fast as you can
and realize
you put it out and no one cares
whatever you thought like you this movie
that you had is not realistic and what
actually happens is like
no one cares and sometimes
they care a little and sometimes they
care
but in a bad way and they they're like
you're bad and this idea is bad and
it's like like
you're like but i lost and everyone's
like this is bad and you should feel bad
and you're like that wasn't what this
isn't the movie i was i was promised a
movie here i love that because it's like
two levels worse than you can imagine
bad is
no one cares worse is everyone hates you
people on hacker news are like you
should be ashamed of yourself
and you're bad and all of your ideas are
bad and
i could have built this in three days
startups are dumb and you're wasting
your time you know it's like it's not
great
and so again the good thing about
launching is you just get you flush this
out of your system you're like yeah okay
cool
this isn't like the movie this is real
life
and here in real life you put out a
launch and most people don't care most
of the time
and you just have to keep launching over
and over and over again and like that's
the work
right well it the movie analogy is so
perfect because when you think about the
launches that most people experience i
think one of the most famous types of
launch that you would see in the world
is a movie launch right it's a movie
premiere that gives you the exact
opposite of impression of how a startup
is right it's like a whole bunch of
press whole bunch of hula hoopla a whole
bunch of people watching that movie
quickly and then it fading
to nothing over the course of like a
month or two
whereas startup is the exact opposite of
that it's like a whole bunch of nobody
gives a [ __ ] for a really long time and
then some point 10 years from now
everyone really cares
but i don't know that people experience
those can you imagine actual time lapse
of the facebook story like if so if
there was a camera mounted on uh mark
zuckerberg's head
for like the first 10 years
what that would actually be versus what
people think it was from watching the
freaking movie like again like it was a
lot of someone sitting at a keyboard
writing code
and like staring at graphs a lot and it
wasn't that interesting like it was not
entertaining
not entertaining well and especially in
the early days where it was exciting to
move to another school like getting
another population of 5 000 users was
like
excite was a big moment inside of the
company yeah well and again if the
actual movie would be them sitting at
their desk in the house being like
typing some stuff into a terminal being
like okay we just launched a new school
and they're like yay
you know what i'm saying like there's no
music there's no backing track
but they're just kind of sitting there
staring at a screen being like okay
oh wait something just broke [ __ ] oh
hold on sight's down okay
all right
all right well it looks good
sites back up all right cool i'll be
back
and so i think movies hurt us here i
guess they're good because they inspire
us but i think
movies mess people up a lot of what they
think normal is well the other thing
that i think movies screw up is is legal
so
i remember
getting our first
angry letter
and like during my startup career
i went from angry letter from law firm
getting sued by the company owned by the
prime minister of italy
getting sued by the ufc
getting very aggressively invited to
testify in front of congress about
sports piracy issue like it was like
that first letter i thought was a
disaster and if only it described all
the other [ __ ] that was gonna happen
like i might have just quit
if i just
shut this down
and like i remember having this
conversation with yc founders now
because it'll always be like oh god we
got sued and i'm just like
and
like
welcome to running a business like you
got sued like check that box off it just
comes with a territory like there's no
way to avoid it like there's not there's
not a universe where you could do
big things and not have these setbacks
where
folks will tell you you're over
folks will tell you
you know
you're bad and you should feel bad
well those are the two maybe those are
the two kind of
silver linings right i think that the
two several lines like one everyone you
respect out there
who's doing great things is dealing with
all this stuff
and so that should make you feel good
like every single person you respect
who's done something hard has dealt with
all this crap and 10x more
so
you're not getting some hand some bad
hand
like everyone gets this handle but it's
not about you
this is just the thing this is just the
game
this is the thing is that you're gonna
every day
have to deal with things that feel like
setbacks well and you can get i think
that's the second silver lining here is
you can get good at this
right like you can get good at dealing
with these setbacks you can actually get
better over time you can
learn how to take a punch
you can't control whether or not you're
gonna have setbacks
you can't you have to like
let it wash over you
but you can completely control your
reaction
yeah that's 100
like what happens in your brain after a
setback happens is within your control
and so you want to have acceptance
yeah some bad stuff's going to happen
and i can't fix it but man you have a
lot of choices in how you deal with
setbacks and it could be anger it could
be fear it could be bartering it could
be denial like we've seen it all
but this is something that you can
practice and get good at
and the folks that are great at whatever
their thing is again like whether it's
athletes or whether it's people putting
out music or making movies
like how do they
like you can get better at dealing with
like criticism or people not caring
and like you can just do that that's
your choice like no there's no
structural reason you can't
have a better or more productive
reaction to the setback right
one this is the only thing that i would
add to that
is that
you're the example
like in
so many things in startups the punch in
the face is the moment where you can
still win points
how you react influences how your
co-founders react how your employees
react influences how they will react
when bad things happen to them
and so like
the the the
uh victory you can rescue out of the
jaws of defeat for any of these setbacks
is reacting in the way
that you'd want everyone else around you
to act react
and like in some fun ways it's like if
people see you taking punches while
they'll or not take punch as well and
one day you're gonna have a large
organization and you're not gonna be
there to cover everyone
and
there will have learned from you they'll
learn the good from you or the bad from
you
but they'll learn from you
and i think that's what's fun you know
sometimes this kind of stuff happens at
yc and it's i actually like
i love it like i love when people are
freaking out and i'm like oh it's gonna
be fine because it's like it turns out
freaking out doesn't help anyone and it
turns out if someone in the room's like
ass gonna be fine
everyone like pauses for moments like me
well [ __ ]
maybe it will be fine
to be really tactical what i what i tell
people to do is you do an inventory
and you're like okay
are we running out of money
okay um
do we still have a product like are we
are we in legal trouble
like
are we arrested um
okay uh like are we am i am i in jail
know okay well
could
could things have been worse like is
this recoverable like like you kind of
just do an inventory where you check in
you go you know reboot the whole machine
yeah and you're like well how bad is
this because sometimes it is really bad
i'm not lying i'm not gonna lie to you
sometimes
it's real bad yeah but a lot of the
times you do this inventory and you like
you're like okay well
we have we have three years of runway
and you know we can do that okay
ah
this isn't bad and that that inventory i
like to call that the worst case
analysis like i actually like to like
okay this bad thing happens what are the
five things we're most afraid of now
and like when we say them out loud do
they just sound less scary
because
they didn't happen
it's like oh all of our customers are
going to leave
have they have they left has anyone even
emailed you
saying they want to leave like
no
learn how to get better at this because
this is the game learn how to take a
punch learn how to get good at doing
hard things
that's that's the message yeah and it's
weird because it's a super power right
like in some weird way the coolest thing
about a startup is that like if you even
if the company fails you can get this
superpower i mean it's great like you
this is a great person to have in your
family this is a great person to have in
your friend like someone that's a rock
yeah someone that will listen like oh
something's bad let me listen like let
me assess the situation tell me what's
going on okay so this okay that
all right like
i could see why this is a setback but
you know
seems like everything else is going okay
so
like that's a valuable person to have
around
oh man all right well to wrap this up
bad things are gonna happen your
reaction is completely under your
control
use it as an opportunity to get better
at taking punches and be the example for
the people around you by uploading
yourself you can uplevel your team too
all right man great chat
sounds good thanks man
[Music]
[Music]
you